Speaker 1: The Ron DeSantis story just
keeps getting more and more insane. Let me
reset this for you. The last time up
until recently that Ron DeSantis, the
Republican very Trumpian Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis was seen in public was December 17th.
On December 17th, he showed up at Big Delicious
Deli and Bakery and in Ocala. And he took a
picture. This is from the Big Delicious Deli and
bakery page on Facebook dated December 17th, they
posted, Even the governor loves bagel licious.
So this was the last time he was seen in public
and nearly two weeks went by. Nearly two weeks
went by, and then all of a sudden the DeSantis
people came out and said, Oh, he was with his wife
at her cancer treatment, Ron DeSantis. His wife
is being treated for breast cancer, and our
thoughts, of course, are with her, and we
hope that the treatment goes well. But that is the
explanation for why he was missing for two weeks
didn't really make sense because apparently that
was only on December 29th that he was with her.
It then got even weirder because on December
30th, the Ron DeSantis official Twitter account
posted the very same picture of DeSantis at
the Big Delicious as if it was that day had
some great bagels from bagel licious in
Ocala stopped by if you're in the area.
So understand that it's very weird. This is
the last public picture of DeSantis anywhere.
We know the picture is from December 17th
because Bagel Licious posted it on December 17th.
And then on the 30th, after tons of people
saying, Where is this guy? Colbert is exploding.
It's complete and total chaos. He's M.I.A.
He says, No, look here. I'm out in public,
but they post a picture that is 13, almost 14
days old. OK, so that's all really, really weird.
But then this is just the worst part of it. And
this is this is just sad. I don't know how else
to say it. This is just sad. There is now video of
Ron DeSantis at a huge concert on New Year's Eve.
With his wife who has cancer unmasked. Everybody
should assess risk for themselves, of course,
you know, your wife has cancer. We
have an insanely contagious variant.
Florida is setting case records every single
day and you go to a massive event without masks.
I mean, what are what? What are you doing that
this is dangerous to her? Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: And so in Florida, you can mark it
down. We will not let anyone shut you down. Yeah.
And we are going to make sure that our rights are
respected and that's what we've done, and that's
what we'll continue to do, so I hope you all have
a very, very good 2020 too. I think there's going
to be a lot of good things on the horizon and
we're looking forward to being able to do a lot
for the state. Looking forward for my wife to
beat breast cancer, which is going to happen.
And so thank you and keep fighting.
Speaker 1: All right, so you get it,
I mean, listen, we all hope
that she beats breast cancer,
bringing her in the middle of peak COVID unmasked
to a huge event where we have a prevalence where
by some estimates, 12 to 18 percent of the country
currently has COVID seems incredibly unwise. But
just a very strange story missing for almost two
weeks says, Well, I'm missing because I was with
my wife at cancer treatment. Except when you look,
that was only on the 29th post a picture from two
weeks earlier saying, Hey, here I am in public
and then you show up unmasked at this. Everything
about this guy disgusts me, and that certainly
doesn't change. With this latest episode,